bonjour à vous je suis heureuse de vous
retrouver alors je vais vous parler
d'abord d'une petite expérience que l'on
peut faire chez soi dans sa cuisine par
exemple et que beaucoup d'entre vous
auront déjà fait je pense vous prenez
lui couper le dos et vous mettez du
poivre dessus de façon à ce qu'ils
couvrent toute la surface puis au milieu
vous déposez une petite goutte de
liquide vaisselle oies et maintenant je
vais vous présenter une autre expérience
encore plus impressionnante
bon j'avoue c'est pas exactement la même
chose mais elle met elle aussi en
lumière les incroyables effets de la
tension de surface
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
cette fameuse tension de surface dont je
vous parlais et bien comme son nom
l'indiqué c'est une énergie une tension
au niveau de la surface d'un liquide ou
d'un solide et c'est ce qui fait par
exemple que certains insectes peuvent
marcher sur l'eau et c'est aussi ce qui
a permis à une équipe de chercheurs
toulousains de réaliser ces images
étonnantes
[Musique]
qui a dit que poésie hydrodynamique ne
faisait pas bon ménage
bon qu'est ce qui se passe dans cette
expérience
revenons à notre tension de surface
c'est elle qui va déterminer par exemple
si une goutte que l'on dépose sur un
solide ou à la surface d'un autre
liquide va perlé ou au contraire c'est
aller complètement
en fait c'est une force qui existe à
l'interface entre deux milieux un
liquide un solide un liquide et l'air ou
même de liquide différent évidemment les
chercheurs de toulouse n'ont pas monté
une expérience avec de l'eau du poivre
et du savon ils ont pris un petit
récipient rempli d'eau et ils ont déposé
à la surface une goutte de
dichlorométhane dudit clos pour les
bricoleurs ce qu'il faut savoir c'est
que pour un liquide la tension de
surface augmente quand la température
diminue et elle dépend aussi de la
présence éventuelle de composer
tensioactifs c'est l'équivalent en
jargon de laboratoire de notre liquide
vaisselle secret de printemps
dans cette expérience on a un
tensioactifs il est ajouté à l'eau et à
la goutte de 10 clos et il porte le
charmant petit nom de c'était ab bromure
de set ils triment et ils ammonium et
celui là je vous mets au défi de le
placer en soirée lorsqu'on est pas une
goutte de 10 clos sur de l'eau elle
commence par s'étaler en formant un film
en expansion autour de sa partie
centrale au lieu de s'amincir
tranquillement sur les bords ce film
forme un bourrelet bourrelet élégant ce
bourg l'élégant va ensuite se fragmenter
ce qui va générer un anneau de
gouttelettes puis le film se rétracte et
aussi que le recommence et le tout va
finir par dessiner une petite fleur
l'élément clé de cette expérience c'est
l'évaporation le diko qui est en train
de s'étaler va s'évaporer
ce qui va faire diminuer la température
de façon plus importante au niveau des
bords du film et du coup à cet endroit
là la tension de surface va être plus
importante et c'est ça qui va former le
bourrelet mais du coup pourquoi ce
phénomène de battement ne serait-ce pas
lié au caractère volatil dudit clos à la
présence du tensioactifs excellente
question
merci véronique paix y en a au moins une
qui suit les gouttelettes de 10 clos
éjecté au moment de la fragmentation du
bourrelet vont abaisser la tension de
surface de l'eau ce qui va permettre au
film de se rétracter
l'évaporation et le tensioactifs ont
ensuite évacué le 10 clos qui s'est
dispersé à la surface de l'eau ce qui
fait qu'on va retrouver l'état initial
et le cycle peut recommencer
bref la dynamique de l'expérience les
pulsations la formation de gouttelettes
toute cette incroyable chorégraphie de
fluides résulte de la bataille acharnée
entre les tensions de surface qui existe
entre l'air et l'eau entre le dit claude
heller
et entre l'eau et le diplôme
ces chercheurs un peu poètes ont
d'ailleurs réussi à créer d'autres
goûtent dynamique en jouant sur les
concentrations de tensioactifs la
compréhension de ces phénomènes
pourraient déboucher sur des
applications thérapeutiques pour
délivrer par exemple de manière plus
efficace des médicaments au niveau des
tissus malades
ces recherches pourraient aussi être
utilisés dans le domaine de la
microfluidique où l'on cherche à
contrôler la forme les mouvements et
l'énergie de différents fluides à de
très petite échelle aller avant de
partir je vous sers une dernière petite
goutte
[Musique]
oui bah oui désolé faut toujours trouver
une blague pourrie pour la fin good que
gut et surtout oubliez pas de vous
abonner
[Musique]